prendre dans la circonscription de
maurice monnier qui étaient contre
christophe lejeune pour la république en
marche et christophe lejeune qui nous
attend depuis la préfecture de vo ouille
bonsoir une première réaction après donc
votre toute première élection en tant
que député à l'assemblée nationale
bonsoir écoutez je suis très très
satisfait de cette première élection
c'est c'est une campagne intense dans ce
qui se termine avec un score très très
acceptable avec 58%
je suis très heureux christophe lejeune
vous faites partie de ces nouveaux
visages alors vous étiez vous êtes maire
d'une petite commune mais peu
d'électeurs vous connaissez dans cette
circonscription vous attribuez votre
victoire
d'abord à l' enthousiasme envers le
nouveau président de la république a
bien évidemment l'enthousiasmé suscité
par emmanuel macron est très fort mais
pour autant les marcheurs ou de saônois
et en particulier de la 2e
circonscription qui m'ont accompagné
d'un point pendant plusieurs semaines
m'ont permis d'avoir ce score ce soir et
c'est avec eux que je veux partager et
bien sûr remercier tous les électeurs de
cette circonscription qui nous ont fait
confiance ce soir christophe lejeune
votre circonscription est particulière
c'est la seule de bourgogne franche
comté qui avait placé marine le pen en
tête du second tour de la présidentielle
est-ce que vous avez un vous souhaitez
vous en parler de dossiers pour
justement essayer de faire reculer le
front national dans votre
circonscription
bien sûr le premier thème c'est la
ruralité il s'agit d'une circonscription
au global et il faut rassembler les élus
locaux qu'ils soient maires communauté
de communes départementaux ou régionaux
pour qu'on est entrain travail
fédérateur et rassembleur au travers de
toutes ces personnes quelles que soient
leurs horizons politiques géographiques
ou professionnelles nous devons avancer
ensemble pour faire gagner la
circonscription et la gêne la
haute-saône d'une manière générale merci
beaucoup christophe le genou
aux députés donc pour la république en
marge de la 2ème circonscription de
haute saône celle de lure luxeuil